all right I'm gonna talk about this
detective Pikachu trailer because when
the first trailer came out I didn't even
watch the trailer was like alright
Pokemon secret's out Pokemon was never
my jam I mean the most I know about
Pokemon is from Super Smash Brothers
card games I play Magic the Gathering
and poker never really felt the need to
catch them although I do really like the
theme song so I was like alright
detective Pikachu not meant for me but
everyone else should have a good time I
hope you have a good time they got a lot
of requests to talk about the trailer I
was like why am I getting all these
requests to talk about this kids trailer
or movie for kids trailer rally or
trailer to a kids movie rather I think
that one's crap it was in a movie
theater long after the first trailer
came out so it wasn't even worth doing a
video long and I saw it the trailer for
detective Pikachu and I was like holy
[ __ ] that actually looks rad so there's
a second trailer I want to talk about it
because like I said it actually looks
rad first of all if anyone's befuddled
or baffled of the fact that Ryan
Reynolds is voicing a character that
simply says pika pika is because this
pokemon trainer can understand him but
no one else can it's a new pokemon
trainer so we're still trying to figure
it out so Ryan Reynolds voices Pikachu
as he's talking to the pokemon trainer
but to everyone else he's pika pika and
as his trailer shows it's detective
Pikachu in the sense that they're
looking for someone who's missing
another a Pokemon fight it looks really
good though like imagine all the Pokemon
fights that you've seen in any form of
animation or video game or whatever but
brought to life like a live-action style
and know for people who are like the
lion Kings not live-action
of course the Pokemon or CGI but
whatever live-action style so when it
gets exciting in the trailer it really
gets exciting also they play a great
song I'm naturally playing a clip cuz I
don't want a copyright strike first of
all but at my ghost busters trailer it
was like ah music that music is
copyright I was like what music it was
literally me sticking the Ghost Buster
song so who knows it might still happen
I'm hoping in this movie it's not just a
bunch of Pokemon and that's that I mean
they're searching for a missing person
so the investigative element I want that
to be good it's like anything they're
still telling a story you need to keep
that intriguing give us some twists give
us some turns
give us some twists and turns however
gonna go back to the fact that Charizard
looks pretty for her and I know him from
Smash Brothers I do not know what world
this takes place in if someone can help
me out
comments-section is right there please
let me know I don't know if this is in
our world and the Pokemon have come to
life in our world and that's a weird
thing to everybody like that Pikachu
floating could be like Oh Pikachu
because Nintendo and then Pikachu's rail
and everyone's like what or
it's just normal that Pokemon are in
this world this is the Pokemon world but
it takes place you know in modern
looking cities it's just what I've seen
in Pokemon I always see trees in fields
and fights I've not seen a city that
looks like a city in Pokemon but like I
said haven't launched a lot of it and I
imagine it's normal to have Pokemon in
this world because their Pokemon
bartenders Pokemon traffic cops I
actually kind of like not knowing that
much about the Pokemon world because I
have all these questions and this
intrigued me toos in it I do remember
Mewtwo so yeah I'm baffled that
detective Pikachu trailer I was like
because people were like why isn't that
on your top ten I was like huh I saw the
trailer I was like alright maybe so if
you were ever like why the pit detective
like watch the trailer you'll probably
really enjoy it the first trailer says
detective Pikachu was great the second
trailer is great it looks like it has
great humor and it's exciting and if
they make that missing person detective
element intriguing is actually a triple
threats lined me up because I see the
potential there the potential of what
this could be it's not marketed to kids
that's what I love about it because at
this point pokemons old enough to words
like you know we have kids and adults
that love this this isn't just for a new
generation of kids to enjoy Pokemon is
for a generation of adults who've wanted
to see something like this ever since
they were kids so yeah detective Pikachu
looks pretty sweet right so the trailer
- detective Pikachu have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]